est-ce que est-ce que les gens portent
sur vous un regard inquisiteur est-ce
que
il pose des questions mais maintenant ça
c'est un petit peu d'accord beaucoup
même
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20h ce soir Dalila bonsoir
alors Dalila je précise que c'est vous
qui avez demandé comme site pas votre
nom de famille évidemment alors avant de
commencer une question d'ordre pratique
vous avez pas un peu chaud là-dessous
qu'est-ce qui me prouve vous êtes pas en
train de me tirer la langue là
et maintenant on passe à notre invité du
samedi 20h
[Musique]
Dalila rebonsoir vous êtes né en octobre
1987 à Dijon vous avez 22 ans votre
maman qui est française a vécu un temps
en Algérie et a voulu garder une trace
de son passage là-bas en appelant ces
deux filles jumelles Dalila et Salwa des
prénoms qui vous rattachent un père qui
ne vous a pas reconnu elle a voulu
que par la suite
[Musique]
qu'on lui reproche pas de nous avoir
appelé par un prénom français d'accord
vous avez vécu toutes les trois dans un
HLM de la banlieue de Dijon vous avez
été scolarisé dans le public et ensuite
dans un lycée privé catholique jusqu'à
un bac pro en bureautique mais ensuite
comme vous étiez bon élève vous êtes
allé à la fac de droite de Dijon votre
mère vous n'avez pas spécialement de
religion mais elle a toujours refusé de
vous servir du port à table
cela vous intrigue et vers l'âge de 13
ans vous commencez à vous poser des
questions et votre mère vous répond un
petit peu comme pour votre prénom c'est
pour pas que vous me le reprochiez plus
tard
alors vous comprenez pas bien vous allez
acheter un exemplaire du Coran un livre
sur les femmes du Prophète Mahomet et
vous apprenez toute seule les raisons
pour lesquelles vous ne devez pas manger
de porc
ma mère elle est même pas musulmane on
comprenait même pas pourquoi elle est
plutôt déiste elle dit qu'elle croit en
Dieu mais elle ne s'arrache aucune
religion donc on a commencé à apprendre
et l'autre manière de vivre d'être
lorsqu'on a appris la religion on s'est
dit mais c'est nous c'est l'autre façon
de penser donc ma sœur et moi on a
commencé à prendre la religion et on l'a
aimé on l'a aimé jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et on l'a pris à devenir
être à devenir musulmane et être
musulmane en étant française chose que à
l'heure actuelle les gens les
politiciens ne veulent pas comprendre à
partir de là toutes vos économies vos
salaires à l'âge de 16 ans vous
travaillez dans un hôtel passe dans
l'achat de livres d'initiation au Coran
et alors
un moment vous portez le foulard dans
six mois
et vous réalisez qu'en fait le véritable
voile islamique c'est le voile intégral
tu voulais pas passer par le
foulard ensuite j'ai appris par la suite
que les écoles
juridiques islamiques
sont divers sur la façon de porter le
voile certains disent qu'on doit voir le
visage mais c'est la minorité et la
majorité disent qu'on doit avoir pour ne
rien voir même pas les yeux et est-ce
qu'on peut nous dire pourquoi dans la
religion musulmane la femme doit se
couvrir autant c'est une prescription
religieuse la vérité la vérité elle est
que il y a des règles on les suit on se
pose même pas question d'accord
vous commencez à porter ce voile
intégral en fin de troisième donc dans
la cour de récréation mais pas en cours
c'était un collège
catholique aussi une motorisé mais
arrivé en classe je me dévoilais
d'accord voilà alors aujourd'hui quand
vous vous promenez comme ça dans la rue
quel regard les gens portent sur vous
Dalila
en même temps le même jour à Dijon il y
avait aucune femme voilée je veux dire à
part quelques-unes en fleurs sinon
c'était je veux dire c'était mal vu on
était des femmes soumises on était des
femmes déjà mariées pour la plupart il
me plaît madame alors que j'avais 17 ans
donc voilà mais les gens se sont
habitués et voilà est-ce que les gens
portent sur vous un regard inquisiteur
est-ce que j'en pose des questions il
pose des questions mais maintenant ça
c'est dissipé un petit peu d'accord
beaucoup même vous vous sentez que ça va
mieux là vous êtes mieux admise plus le
temps passe en fait avant les gens dans
la rue j'ai subi des agressions j'ai
suivi des insultes maintenant aussi il y
a des il y en a encore mais largement
moins est-ce que vous avez été agressé
verbalement et physiquement qu'est-ce
qui vous quand il vous agresse
verbalement par exemple
ça rejoint le
rayon de Monsieur
c'est à dire
après
bien plus bien plus gros mais enfin
c'est le même sens quelqu'un a voulu
vous étrangler oui personne qui m'a dit
on n'est pas l'organisation elle est
venue vers moi elle m'a prise par la
gorge mais je lui ai dit on n'est pas
leur histoire on est en France je suis
française et je porterai ce voile même
si tu m'intéresses je le garde et je
l'ai gardé ça qu'après je l'ai toujours
et la personne qui vous a agressé
physiquement qui a essayé de vous
étrangler c'était un homme une femme
jeune
mais j'ai même pas porté plainte je veux
dire j'ai porté ce voyage je savais à
quoi m'attendre alors ce qui était assez
extraordinaire effectivement c'est que
les gens qui vous voient comme ça vous
crois soumise obligé de porter ce voile
à cause d'un homme soit un père soit un
frère soit un mari et en fait non
personne c'est ça qu'il faut dire quand
même parce que là ça pose le problème
d'une façon un peu différente
effectivement personne vous oblige à
vous habiller comme ça faut le dire
c'est votre décision de citoyenne
française
très importante alors pour vous le voile
est pas un handicap aujourd'hui puisque
à la Faculté on a le droit de porter le
voile ça dans les collèges et lycée
c'est interdit mais elle a faculté on a
le droit donc faites vos études de droit
simplement vos professeurs vous
demandent de vous dévoiler pour les
examens c'est bien ça Dalila et j'ai
passé des examens ils m'ont dit on vous
a reconnu on sait que c'est vous donc
même c'est même pas la peine de vous
dévoiler
pas extrémiste je vais te passer à la
fiste vous n'êtes pas du tout
alors en gros quand on voilà vous ce que
vous pensez en fait c'est que les les
filles françaises aujourd'hui cherchent
à ressembler à celle qu'on voit dans
Secret Story et pour vous c'est un peu
l'abomination ça c'est à dire la
marchandisation du corps de la femme moi
ça représente vraiment
ce qu'on
veut c'est la femme française et moi
jamais de ma vie je serai comme ça
d'accord
alors vous dites ce sont les dictatures
qui imposent aux gens comment s'habiller
et comme la France c'est pas une
dictature on ne peut pas m'imposer
comment s'habiller franchement ça
représente vraiment
le projet de Monsieur Copé représente
vraiment mal un pays démocratique
vraiment pas
se mêler de la religion vraiment pas
mais non on se met pas de la religion en
plus vous n'avez aucune science en
matière de religion vous ne savez pas
rechercher rechercher c'est quoi la
vérité dans la religion et après vous
pouvez discuter avec des filles qui
portent voilà il y a quand même des
millions de musulmans qui vivent leur
islam en France sans porter le voile
intégral on peut chacun ses convictions
ceci étant chaque pays a son
fonctionnement par exemple en Arabie
Saoudite sur le construire une église en
Arabie Saoudite on peut pas on pourrait
aussi penser qu'en France tout le monde
suit une certaine règle comme en Arabie
saoudite
à la femme la femme là je suis d'accord
la femme elle est soumise on appose à
des femmes qui sont qui peuvent ne pas
même pas croire en Dieu apporter un vol
qu'elles n'ont pas voulu le voile doit
être voulu ce que vous dites là c'est
que vous êtes contre cette police
religieuse les types qui ont des petites
baguettes comme ça dans la rue qui
embêtent les femmes qui qui sont disent
mal
Jean-François vous avez pris la tête un
petit peu de la campagne antiburca en
tous les cas vous allez pris de vitesse
la mission parlementaire qui doit donner
ses conclusions fin janvier vous avez
des positions qui sont même plus dures
je dirais que celle de Brie sorte feu
qui lui est pour l'interdiction
uniquement dans les services publics et
vous allez jusqu'à prenez une amende de
750 euros pour s'habiller comme ça oui
je dois dire en vous écoutant que tout
cela a renforcé les les convictions qui
sont les miennes et je me permets de
vous dire pas simplement les miennes je
voudrais d'ailleurs vous dire vous avez
plusieurs fois employé le terme
d'insultes je n'ai pas du tout le
sentiment en prenant cette position
d'insulter qui que ce soit je vous
disiez tout à l'heure en me regardant
puisque en fait c'est la seule chose que
nous pouvons faire c'est échanger des
des regards
là où moi je pense que le premier
contact entre deux personnes avant même
le regard c'est le sourire et que moi je
peux vous sourire et que malheureusement
je ne sais jamais si vous répondez à mon
sourire mais en tout cas sachez une
chose c'est que tout à l'heure vous
m'avez dit Monsieur Gobet vous ne
connaissez pas la religion connaissez-la
et voyez les règles avant de juger moi
je voudrais vous dire que la
particularité de la France comme
d'autres pays c'est d'être une
démocratie et c'est d'être une
démocratie laïque qu'est-ce que c'est la
laïcité c'est pas du tout la négation
des religions c'est le fait que chacun
puisse exercer son culte s'il le
souhaite dans le respect de celui de
l'autre et moi personnellement comme
beaucoup beaucoup de Français parce que
c'est ce qu'il y a fait le creuset de
notre pays
je suis évidemment très respectueux du
fait que chacun appartienne à une
communauté religieuse associative
politique mais à une condition c'est que
les règles de la communauté soient
subordonnée subordonnée aux règles de la
République pas égal aux règles de la
République subordonnée aux règles de la
République et parmi les règles de la
République il y a celles du
vivre-ensemble or pour que l'on puisse
vivre ensemble il faut que l'on
connaisse l'identité de l'autre et leur
premier élément de l'identité c'est le
visage et donc il faut pas qu'il y ait
de doute là-dessus c'est pas le voile
qui est en cause c'est le fait d'avoir
le visage intégralement dissimulée parce
que du coup il n'y a plus d'identité et
pour moi le problème il est là parce que
au-delà de votre personne il y a en
réalité une double difficulté le premier
c'est la question du respect des femmes
et la seconde c'est la question de la
sécurité et Madame moi je voudrais vous
dire avec respect que on ne peut pas
accepter que dans une société comme la
nôtre il y a une situation dans laquelle
un enseignant puisse remettre un enfant
à la sortie de l'école à une personne
dont il ne voit pas le visage de la même
manière on ne peut pas banaliser le
phénomène dans lequel dans une vie en
société une partie des gens choisiraient
au quotidien d'avoir le visage
complètement dissimulé donc
méconnaissable vous savez par exemple
que le pèlerinage de la Mecque vous le
savez sans doute le voile intégral est
interdit j'ai consulté le président du
Conseil français du culte musulman il a
été auditionné par la mission
parlementaire il a été reçu par les
députés UMP j'étais présent il nous a
dit c'est dans les minutes du texte que
ça n'était pas le port du voile intégral
une prescription religieuse pour moi le
voile intégrale le voit l'intégrale pour
moi ça n'est pas une question religieuse
je me pose à toute stigmatisation j'ai
été cho par le débat sur les minarets
pour cette raison là le véritable sujet
ça n'est surtout pas de stigmatiser tel
ou telle communauté religieuse dans les
manifestations
de banaliser ce phénomène permettez-moi
de vous dire s'il vous plaît que en
France ce qui représente l'islam
comme étant
déjà pour affirmer que ils ont
conscience quelle science il est quoi il
a été élu madame et oui figurez-vous que
c'est pas grave c'est juste un cliché
non c'est pas un cliché c'est parce que
comme
on est marié
ma difficulté avec vous je me permets de
vous le dire c'est que c'est extrêmement
difficile de discuter si je puis dire
d'égal à égal avec quelqu'un dont on ne
voit pas le visage j'ai beaucoup de mal
à parler avec vous je ne vous vois pas
c'est normal c'est normal mais c'est
très difficile si parce que la société
moderne la société organisée la société
du respect elle passe par le fait d'une
rencontre entre des visages entre mais
bien sûr mais vous voyez la difficulté
que j'ai à vous parler si ça répond aux
mouvements
nous allons demander
l'expatron du conseil institutionnel ce
n'est pas dans la Constitution
malheureusement concernant Dalila alors
est-ce que vous acceptez qu'elle soit
comme ça
je trouve que ça vous dérange pas le
vent du monde et je considère que ceux
qui envisagent de légiférer sur ce sujet
près d'une très grave responsabilité
parce que vous allez voir resurgir le
même problème dans d'autres religions
par exemple
pendant la religion juive on affiche
c'est vrai dans la rue des tenues qui ne
sont pas les tenues classiques les
racines voulaient dire avec les
papillons le plafond la rodée noire et
ce qui fait que même si vous n'avez pas
l'intention vous les reconnaissez ça
peut ça peut vous choquer demain par
exemple si vous avez une majorité qui
n'est pas celle d'aujourd'hui qui
prendra une manifestation une loi
contraire pour pour la religion juive ou
toute autre religion peu importe le
principe le principe de laïcité formelle
c'est de ne pas toucher aux religions ce
que vous dites et pour moi aberrant
pourquoi mais pourquoi mais pourquoi
parce que le problème n'est pas de
savoir si il est des juifs pratiquants
qui ont comme vous dites des papillotes
ou bien un
ecclésiaste catholique qui a sa tenue ou
bien naturellement un musulman le
problème ou aboutissent le seul sujet
qui nous importe
c'est la dissimulation du visage
mais c'est un élément majeur d'identité
et de vivre ensemble et bien je constate
que sur ce point nous sommes en
désaccord nous sommes et je le regrette
mais je veux simplement vous dire que
pour ceux qui me concerne que vous dites
inimaginable de construire la société de
demain avec des gens qui vivent ensemble
sans pouvoir reconnaître leur visage
Michel je vous écoute je suis pas
d'accord avec Monsieur Dumas sur le fait
que on peut porter un turban pour pour
ainsi qu'on peut porter une kippa pour
un juif sans sans on peut pas comparer
avec la burqa ou avec le voile intégral
pour moi l'intégrale c'est une négation
totale de sa personnalité et là le débat
et le oui mais là c'est c'est un
avilissement c'est on est persuadé
endroit chez les catholiques où on nous
voit jamais le visage de la femme par
exemple vous les voyez pas peut-être que
dans votre cas peut-être que dans votre
cas c'est un choix personnel mais on ne
peut pas nier que dans un grand nombre
de cas c'est le mari qui va imposer à sa
femme que personne aucun autre homme que
lui ne peut voir ni ses mains ni son
visage vous savez très bien que ça
existe dans la religion musulmane et que
pas mal de femmes aujourd'hui ont la
burqa parce qu'elles ne veulent pas
choquer leur mari et que si on autorise
aujourd'hui le port de la burqa ou le
port de la du voile intégral à des
femmes même qui comme vous l'ont choisi
à titre personnel et seul en son âme est
conscience d'autres femmes pourront le
faire mais imposer par leur mari et
c'est ça qui me choque aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on me dit c'est ma liberté de
porter un voile intégral il y a par
exemple des libertés qui sont interdites
on n'est pas libre de se balader
totalement dénudés on n'est pas libre de
se balader avec en détenant des armes de
la droite il y a évidemment des des
interdictions c'est comme ça qu'on
organise une société et vous vous voulez
ça ça rentre dans l'interdiction et bien
oui je n'ai pas dans le domaine des
libertés se promener avec des armes à la
main ça c'est vrai vous avez raison mais
ça c'est l'ordre social mais ça n'a rien
à voir avec le la comportement
vestimentaire mais c'est pas un
comportement vestimentaire en
dissimulant son visage on dissimule son
identité monsieur Dumas je suis obligé
de vous dire qu'en dissimulant son
identité on pose des problèmes de
sécurité je suis désolé si elle n'est
pas respecté c'est exactement le
raisonnement qu'on a connu des
législateurs de Vichy je me permets de
vous le dire mais si je trouve que cette
formule je le regrette parce que j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour vous et
profondément insuffisant et elle n'a
absolument rien à voir et c'est ce que
vous dites c'est je pense mais vous
savez ce que c'était la législation de
Vichy elle conduisait des hommes à la
mort et évidemment et vous êtes bien
placé pour le savoir comment
osez-vous faire des comparaisons comme
celle-là parce que ce texte est là ce
texte que vous préconisez et là demain
sera peut-être avec votre majorité
d'interdions
du mavicie s'est interdire à des hommes
et des femmes d'exercer des professions
d'envoyer leurs enfants à l'école
c'était la conduite à des arrestations
et des déportations ça n'a rien à voir
avec société
la législation
le temps nous est malheureusement
imparti d'alliage vous laisse le mot de
la fin je vous remercie d'avoir eu le
courage de témoigner parce que j'ai pas
souvent vu de femmes voilées à la
télévision témoigner donc c'est assez
courageux est-ce que vous avez un mot de
conclusion
concernant la sécurité je suis d'accord
avec vous toutes les femmes qui ont des
enfants qui vont chercher leurs enfants
à l'école si
reconnais pas elle peut très bien se
dévoiler les visages devant elle si il y
a un contrôle au niveau de la police au
niveau des douanes il n'y a pas de
problème on se dévoile mais dehors les
gens les passants n'ont pas avoir mon
visage pour quelle raison pour quelle
raison un homme ou une femme doit avoir
mon visage non mais je refuse monsieur
vous savez pourquoi parce que c'est ma
religion et en tant que religieuse je
dois porter ce voilà
à tes légifé d'un Coran et vous voulez
vous voulez faire une loi pour lui j'ai
fait ré vous savez qu'en tant que
musulmane je n'ai pas je n'ai pas le
droit je n'ai pas mon devoir en moi et
de respecter ma religion et de la
pratiquer comme bon me semble sauf que
malheureusement en respectant les autres
les prescriptions religieuses dans la
République française sont subordonnés au
respect des lois de la République je
suis désolé de vous le dire parce qu'il
y a d'autres solutions
je suis pas hors-la-loi demain
vous allez en faire une et je serai
hors-la-loi vous imaginez ah mais
handicapé d'accord moi je vis seul avec
ma ma mère et ma sœur on porte voilà
une chose
mademoiselle je voudrais quand même
rappeler une chose c'est que l'école
nous avons eu le même débat sur les
signes
ostentates religieux ostentatoire à
l'école et rappelez-vous qu'on avait dit
la même chose et pour autant parce que
les Français sont profondément
républicains profondément respectueux de
la législation il n'y a eu absolument
aucun problème d'application de cette
loi aucun problème mais le 19 mai
de toute confession le 19 mai 2004 l'ONU
a jugé cette loi comme étant comme étant
la tolérance religieuse vous savez
pourquoi Monsieur parce qu'on respecte
les religions
d'intolérance bien religieuses dans le
monde bien mais en tous les cas merci à
tous pour débat tout à fait étonnant à
la télévision française
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu